um how's everything I know you got the
new album coming out next Friday
um now yeah we're just reloading it next
Friday
um Family Moolah now but you know as
opposed to music man I'm doing good
though man that's good I'm doing good
mentally you family you happy oh for
sure for sure definitely happy man
um
independent now so that's important yeah
I always felt like you know because I
for a while you were um I forget which
what was the major label you've been
putting stuff out with was it capital
Motown yeah one more time I always felt
like you were kind of built for the
independent [ __ ] yeah me too man me too
but at the same time you know uh
throughout my 10-year run I definitely I
saw every size for Independence uh TIG
label so yeah because to think it's a
game error for people who don't know
there was like a point in time where you
would kind of cool off but it was also
because you weren't allowed to release
music for sure for sure that for sure
that yeah so when I couldn't release
music man you know it just really put a
dark cloud over my head you know what
I'm saying Dark Cloud where I couldn't
record I didn't want to hear the radio
you know what I'm saying yeah was it
like a point in time where you felt like
you might have been like kind of dealing
with some depression or you just kind of
were like down in terms of just like
you're just on the music industry in
general I would just say depressed bro
but coming from that situation from the
litigation where I couldn't drop and
that and
watching your pills just go up knowing
you can't go up you know I mean but I'm
still doing shows and
my heart just went into normal yeah